christian koster bestimmt gerne wo's
lang geht auch unter ghana seines
vereins präsident des fc sion
polarisiert
aber wer ist dieser mann
leser ganz so
für denselben denke gern
woran die profile warum die antwort
juli
[Musik]
seit jahren fährt christian costa
ferrari immer das neueste modell
wissen sie das provoziert nati die sich
provozieren lassen wollen die einen
finden ferraris für die anderen halt
nicht
[Musik]
ist ja constanta 56 walliser und für
alle nur cc doch wer steht hinter diesen
initialen ich war gewarnt cc sehr
eigenwillig selbstherrlich skrupellos
ein machtmensch
mehrmals habe ich zehn den letzten
monaten begleitet
als erstes nahm er mich mit auf eine
baustelle
hier zeigt sich was er sicher ist ein
cleverer geschäftsmann cc hat ein
eigenes architekturbüro und handelt mit
immobilien
meine strategie
es war praktisch alle grundstücke und
den autobahnausfahrten zu kaufen und
gewerbebauten zu errichten im
einzugsgebiet der ruhr von brandis prix
hier bei der ausfahrt cios bauen wir ein
einkaufszentrum für eine große nationale
kette und schon geht es weiter
das ist typisch für cc und wird sich
noch mehrmals wiederholen er hetzt von
termin zu termin arbeitet viel und
verdient noch mehr
sein portfolio umfasst gewerbebauten und
privatgebäude und richtet sich an eine
gutbetuchte klientel zum beispiel in
montreux als freddie mercury naoto kan
hat er seine wohnung gebäude da vorne
mit den glockentürmen je auf der zweiten
etage verkaufte ich einen anderen
musiker den führen koch der englischen
königin und daher dritten stock kaufte
mir ihm eine wohnung ab nach seiner
rückkehr aus new york
was macht einen beachtlichen teil des
gebäudes aus zu seinen kunden gehörten
auch claude nobs cc kannte den kürzlich
verstorbenen gründer des jazz festivals
vom motor schon lange claude nobs wollte
das quartier um sein geburtshaus neu
bauen lassen
dafür kam für ihn nur einer infrage er
schätzte ccs geradlinigkeit auch wenn
der im umgang nicht immer der einfachste
ist vielleicht ist er manchmal etwas
hart etwas schroff aber ist nun mal so
er ist präsident eines fußballvereins
und hat bauprojekte überall in der
schweiz dann ist das normal
seine große qualität ist seine
ehrlichkeit ist ein wille bis zum
schluss zu gehen
wer entscheidet schnell doch vorher hört
dazu und sagt dass dank so machen wir
so machen wir es gilt auch hier zählt
vor dem stadion seines fc sion
der klub ist der stolz des kantons er
verbindet unter und oberwallis
der präsident hält ihn am leben als sein
persönliches spielzeug
er zahlt er befiehlt
[Musik]
vor dem spiel gegen den fc luzern im
vergangenen oktober steht einer im
mittelpunkt cc ist bekannt für knackige
aussagen und seinen ehrgeiz
nach einer niederlage heißt es aufstehen
und wieder den sieg wahrt und im
berufsleben man darf nie sorgen muss man
angehen sie ausmerzen und weiter
der präsident spricht aus eigener
erfahrung
seine erste amtszeit hat die 1998 fast
den ruin geendet wenig später kehrte cc
als retter zurück auf den thron
selbst walliser sagen so etwas sei nur
in ihrem kanton möglich
als einstiger torhüter in der höchsten
schweizer spielklasse kennt er das
geschäft ist strapaziert die nerven
wie bei diesem foul an gegner luzern
[Applaus]
gerät sein team in rückstand die re 10
grad
und der trainer in rücklage
dann drängt es den präsidenten zur
trainerbank
gelinde gesagt ein irritierendes
rollenverständnis was will der trainer
macht hilft der präsident dass alle uhr
bewahrer und sich konzentrieren kann der
trainer zufrieden sein nur ruhig bleibt
auch der präsident nicht zu sehr liebte
seinen verein zu viel geld steckt er
ihnen jährlich bis zu 3 millionen
franken
[Applaus]
[Musik]
umso wichtiger kehrt sein team die
partie so steigerte seinen markt wird
darauf baut der präsident ohne erlöse
aus spielertransfers müsste er noch
größere löcher in der clubkasse stopfen
dazu sei er nicht bereit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
besiegt scheint wenig zu besänftigen
schnell verliert die geduld und
wechselnden trainer oft gleich mehrmals
pro saison ein groteskes trauerspiel das
cc aufführt an so sollte auch aus diesem
handshake schon bald ein abschiedsgruß
werden
[Applaus]
im wallis finde ich nicht viele leute
die den verein finanziell unterstützen
können ich kann es mir erlauben mich
viel arbeit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber ob sie nun alleine sind aber nicht
man muss spiele gewinner eine andere
regel gibt es im fußball nicht nur mit
seiner ungeduld tcc dem erfolg wohl
selbst am meisten im weg
allerdings geht er ihn ganz unbekümmert
an einer messe in martigny cc zeigt sich
volksnah und bleibt trotzdem distanziert
[Musik]
er bleibt nur stehen wenn es sich lohnt
das geschäft ich immer dazu mit meiner
tätigkeit muss man die treffen and habe
gestalten jede begegnung kann zu kleinen
oder größeren stehen größe und aus denen
wieder
cc handel zählten ohne kalkül
dennoch gilt er suche für sein
engagement wertschätzung und finde er
respekt
[Musik]
hoch über sie residiert cc hier denke
ich hält also der königshof ein könig
der ohne seine familie lebt ccs erste
frau verstarb wie seine mutter früh und
von seiner zweiten hat er sich getrennt
in guten wie er sagt bei ihr wohnen die
gemeinsamen kinder die wir noch
kennenlernen werden
cc gewährt und seine kurze audienz das
ist wohl schon viel für den dauer
beschäftigten und vielleicht gar ein
vertrauensbeweis
doch auch hier gibt er den takt vor cc
pflegt seine prinzipien ein paar
aufnahmen müssen genügen die rechnung zu
erkennen zumindest der luxus leistet ihm
gesellschaft
das wirtschaftsmagazin bilanz schätzt
sein vermögen auf 250 bis 300 millionen
franken bearbeitet mit seinem
architekturbüro
ich habe keine bewunderung für den luxus
geld ist für mich eine notwendigkeit und
projekte voranzutreiben vorwärts zu
kommen dagegen empfindlich respekt für
die leute denen es gelingt das geld
anderen zu geben damit es diesen besser
geht
cc vereint gegensätze er schätzt
bodenständigkeit und leistet sich viel
luxus
er kalkuliert kühl als unternehmer und
liebt das irrationale fußballgeschäft
erstrahlt unnahbarkeit aus und das
private einblicke zu er will geduzt
werden
ccs dominant und kann kumpelhaft fast
fürsorglich sein und sogar humor
[Gelächter]
dazu würden
ccs tage wegen früh schon um viertel vor
sechs steht er im fitnesscenter des fc
sion dies dreimal die woche
bei alles selbst disziplin auch hier
gönnt sich cc luxus einen privattrainer
was nichts an seiner überzeugung ändert
jeder müsse sich alleine durchs leben
schlagen
geschenkt wird einem nichts das leben in
den bergen ist härter da muss man immer
kämpfen
[Musik]
dann zeigt mir cc wo sich die reinsten
fc sion wie kalt soll er denkt gerne
groß hier an ein modernes
trainingszentrum
in diesem abschnitt werden wäre ein
gedecktes spielfelder richten
ich habe im winter schwierige
klimatische bedingungen haben werden
einen kunstrasen ein baum den dachstuhl
restaurieren und den eingangsbereich
dank solarzellen auf dem dach werden wir
erneuerbare energien
die umsetzung dieses projekts steht noch
aus der fußball bietet ccb noch platz
für träume
die mannschaft muss sich bis auf
weiteres mit dürftigen verhältnissen
zufrieden geben
beobachtet wird sie dabei oft von
barthelemy costa den sohn des
präsidenten
der 19-jährige steht dem team nahe
vielleicht manchmal gar näher als den
vater
es ist klage konnte nicht immer sehr
präsent seien wegen des fonds bereits
des architekturbüros aber war immer für
uns da hat mir sorgen fand er immer zeit
mit uns zu spielen
da hat uns immer ins stadion mitgenommen
anwesen war bei unserem letzten besuch
im februar auch der kurz zuvor
verpflichtete neue trainer
unterdessen wurde victor muñoz schon
wieder aus dem amt gekippt
in ccs wallis herrschen raue sitten nur
jeder weiß auf welche spieler sich hier
ein lässt
inzwischen kennen die trainer die gefahr
zur bloßen marionette zu verkommen im
kabarett costa
[Musik]
die schaltzentrale von ccs reich
befindet sich in martigny der board dr
liegt der geschäftssitz von fußballclub
und architekturbüro das büro der
gelernte hochbauzeichner selbst
aufgebaut
den jahresumsatz beziffert er auf über
250 millionen franken weil sie selber
präparat april den gewinn auf etwa 30
millionen rund 50 mitarbeiter
beschäftigt cc meisten seit jahren einen
personalverschleiß wie beim fußball kann
er sich hier nicht erlauben in einem
büro gibt es keinen totomat hier hatte
man keine tabelle nach jedem wochenende
du bewegst dich nicht in der
kurzlebigkeit des sports wo du sofort
leistung zeigen muss
in der architektur hat man mehr zeit
hier brauche ich leute mit erfahrung auf
die ich mich verlassen kann
die firma gut kennen und meine
anforderungen erfüllen als patron
toleriere er fehler sagt cc solange sie
sich nicht oft wiederholen würden auch
er sei nicht perfekt immerhin in seinem
büro steht prominent das geschenk eines
geschäftspartners es passt zum leitwolf
cc doch wölfe leben im rudel vielleicht
sind sie auch deshalb nicht seine
lieblingstiere
[Musik]
ich wäre lieber ein adler als ein ball
kann über die berge und wälder fliehen
er sieht die welt von oben und hat eine
gewisse macht was macht das leben als
makler interessant
ccs adler steht auf dem flugplatz in
zell ein eigener business jet für 10
millionen franken geplant waren diesen
tagen flug nach lugano da nebel eine
landung verunmöglichte zur cc kurzerhand
einen anderen termin vor und machte sich
auf nach genf
rechenschaft ablegen für sein tun
ja aber nur gegenüber sich selbst
wettbewerb ist sein antrieb
wenn sie feinde haben wissen sie
wenigstens dass diese leute sie mit
ihrer eifersucht beschäftigen die sich
nur noch mit sich selbst
mir ist das alles nicht richtig im
französischen sagt man tschüs
also das ist mir egal
ccj keinen konflikt und er provoziert
gerne ihren der generalprobe zur club
gala
pd
über die lande und die gleichen
[Musik]
si
die aufschrift ein scherz der techniker
man kennt ihn
warum warum warum mit der philanthrop
ich habe nicht gesehen dass jesus der
aufstand war dass ihre idee aber sie
sehen ein wenig der gottes fc sion gar
nicht es gibt nur einen gott
doch das bin nicht ich ccs macht geht
allerdings so weit dass er den komikern
der gala die pforten umschreibt
[Musik]
jeder versuch berge die gefahr des
scheiterns sagt cc er mag keine zufälle
und schon gar keine pannen
zumal wenn über 6.000 zahlende gäste an
die gala des fc sion strömen dann ihnen
fließe an diesem abend über 800000
franken gewinnen die klubkasse cc das
muss ihm zuerst einmal einer nachmachen
in der schweiz
[Musik]
wenn der gastgeber ruft kommt die
walliser prominenz auch
polizeikommandant christian warum das in
cc in seinem lied hoch nimmt zieht er
ihn nach
er hat eine gewinnende art
er kann sich sehr schnell von trainer
trainer aber ich garantiere
er hat ein gutes herz und ist nahe bei
den leuten er ist immer bereit zu helfen
meint der zuspruch den er an der gala
erfahre zeige dass er kein so schlechter
mensch sei wie man in der deutschschweiz
finden
manchmal buchstäblich schwer fassbar
bleibt er aber selbst für tochter
charlene und der gala verkauft die
tombolalose
weil er eine schwierige arbeit hat ist
eher schwierig zu erreichen gelingt ist
ihr ihn einzufangen
es ist schwierig aber manchmal muss man
ihn holen
wie ist denn die beziehung zu seinem
vater
ich habe eine relativ gute beziehung zu
ihm aber wir sind zwei starke charaktere
manchmal ist es schwierig aber es geht
die 14-jährige verein mit bruder
barthelemy und dem vater der schalk
verrät
sie müssen arbeiten um die dummheiten
des vaters zu bezahlen
neben cc sitzen gala tänzerinnen sein
vorbild jedoch meidet das
scheinwerferlicht vater marcel der 80
jährige freut sich still
ich bin sehr stolz wer sich durchschlägt
er macht seine sache ziemlich gut
ich habe zwar immer etwas angst er
könnte sich übernehmen habe ich bin
glücklich so wie er ist eigenwillig sei
selbstherrlich und skrupellos wurde ich
vor drehbeginn gewarnt cc ist ein
machtmensch doch er weiß auch mit
erwartungshaltungen zu spielen
die räume sind komplett verschieden hier
muss ich einen ganzen saal animieren
wenn ich dagegen hinter der trainerbank
stehen wenn wir gewinnen ist das etwas
anders
wenn du koch bist und das essen
zubereitet ist machst du auch nicht
dasselbe wie eine mauer
gc lässt mich im zwiespalt er ist
schwierig und provokativ gleichzeitig
ein mann mit charisma und selbstironie
die sensoren
der sohn
unsere glocken
matschie
sie lassen will
für die
ich will
langsam zu lesen
[Musik]
[Applaus]